[Musique]
parle-moi de ton passe temps
bompastor la course permanente à brion
et moi j'apprends à cames
la course est pas un passe temps quant à
moi j'avais pris ma décision
la course c'est pour moi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai parlé à bob links qui aujourd'hui
fait beaucoup de talent mais il te sert
à rien parce que tu as de la mer mais il
aura une nouvelle voiture l'an prochain
et il veut que la pilote pour lui soit
des gestes que ton père vadim fiche
complètement de ce qui peut bien dire je
veux devenir un champion mais ça sera
pas possible si je cours pour moi pas le
ch l'avait plus important tu ton propre
père j'ai pas fais de toi ce que tu es
portes-tu finisse comme ça si tu es
fréquentes hui la clique qui l'entourent
thil et sera très vite et plus grands le
lien familial autre superstar locale sam
la légende monroe je vous dois être le
premier à vous souhaiter à nouveau la
bienvenue n'ai pas peur de faire frotter
des brèves
devient l'enjeu numéro 10 o
ce qu'on peut savoir ce qu'il se passe
entre vous et votre fils carré fils
souvent opposés les uns aux autres dans
les courses droite du tour inhabituel
line ce que tu mets ton père dans tous
ses états n'y a pas qu'à lui que ça
arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
reculez ruffieux reculer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de nos jours disait je veux que tu
reviendras tu
il prendra bien cette fois
vu que ce soit toi qui pilote guy mieux
que toi est le plus à même de perpétuer
la légende des menottes et sérieux
sérieux comme jamais
k
[Musique]